okay people come from all over the world  to see their acrobatic act who am i  talking to talking about well they're a  fixture on the las vegas strip and  tonight you're getting your own personal  performance from cirque du soleil here  is kah from the mgm grant  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  so  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  examples  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  uh  yeah  that's applause  nikki we're just laughing as we were  watching that can you do any of that  that just happened  that's kind of how i limber up but  here's my new year's resolution i by  next year this evening michael i want to  be able to you're going to lay on your  back and get your feet up in the air and  i'm just going to do those twirls around  you're just going to spin me around on  the show next year yes okay okay well  that's our pledge to you right now